bill you were here today at story Expo
2014 discussing suspense as it relates
to screenwriting give us some examples
of creating suspense and how important
it is story suspense suspense is the
anticipation of action it's not action
itself the minute you have action the
suspense is gone but what you want to do
is create suspense in ways and actually
be anything that can be something
blowing up you know we the the joke I
was talking about in class was the red
LED bombs that the bombs that have the
countdown on it that you can only read
if you're going to be blown up because
like no you know no one's going to stand
that close to the bomb but as that
countdown
that's that creates the suspense and
that suspense can be anything from
notorious has a bucket of champagne
bottles at a party and as the champagne
bottles get pulled out and people are
drinking and drinking and drinking then
finally we get to the point where
there's no more champagne bottles
somebody has to go to the wine cellar
and that's where Cary Grant and great
Bergman are poking around because they
believe that the bad guys are doing
something that's hidden in that wine
cellar
so the suspense is will they run out of
champagne before they find the evidence
and get out of there and because that's
a cool movie doesn't quite work out the
way they planned and they get caught so
when you see someone write a script in a
rush suspense what are some ways to slow
it down and you see someone get right
yeah sleeping you you don't you don't
want to you don't want to jump straight
to the action what you want to do is you
want to create the suspense the
anticipation because that the Hitchcock
said that you can have a bomb under a
table and it explodes and it's
surprising and you have like maybe five
seconds of the audience going oh my god
a bomb exploded or you can put the bomb
onto the table the audience sees the
bomb then you have the two guys have a
conversation about anything the weather
sports scores and the audience is going
don't you stop talking about sports
scores there's a bomb under the table
it's going to kill you you know you've
got to do something about it and that's
what creates the suspense so what you
want to do is figure out the ways to
draw things out and
I mentioned the class a crappy movie
called flesh + blood where one of the
characters is going is trying to poison
somebody with their with their water and
so they take the pitcher of water and
they put poison in it and what happens
is then that character they're trying to
kill takes the water and pours it into
other people's glasses you're going you
can't do that you can't do that you're
going to kill innocent people and then
pours the water to his glass and as he
pours the water in his glass gets ready
to take a drink and then somebody says
something to him and he stops and has a
conversation with the glass so close to
him drinking it and if that guy drinks
it first and dies then the person who
poisoned it can tell everybody else not
to drink their water so it builds
suspense in two ways that way the if
somebody else drinks first they've
killed in it as a person if this guy
continues this conversation for too long
those people are going to drink first
it's going to be over what are some ways
you've seen screenwriters try to draw
out suspense but it falls flat usually
what happens is they don't try to draw
it out they don't tell they don't
suspense is based around dramatic irony
where the audience knows something that
the characters do not and often what
happens is they don't tell the audience
so the audience has no idea that the
glass of water is poisoned or whatever
and so when the person drinks that they
they die and you there's no suspense
there suspense is telling the audience
ahead of time what's going on so the
audience knows that the characters don't
and that ends up being the big issue
sometimes with suspense that doesn't
work
you